with Avengers infinity war set to bring
together story arcs from almost 20
Marvel movies over the past decade
there's no denying sheer force and
influence of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it wasn't always smooth
sailing Marvel's first misstep was Iron
Man 2 which lacked the finesse fans
would eventually come to expect he is
how one of the franchise's least liked
movies almost derailed the Marvel
Cinematic Universe weak and clunky one
of the most scattered and unfocused
films in the MCU Iron Man is essentially
two movies crammed into one we begin
with Tony Stark coming to grips with not
just his newfound superhero status but
the fact that the arc reactor in his
chest is slowly poisoning him
but wait there's an old diorama made by
Tony's father Howard that holds the key
to a new element that just so happens to
be the exact material Tony needs to save
his life and it just gets sillier from
there
which is a coconut
No
between scattered action set-pieces and
bizarre sight stories there are also the
Easter eggs the early days of the MCU
saw the studio dropping in nods and
references that didn't feel completely
organic to the stories the films were
telling one of the biggest rotten eggs
is a prototype Captain America shield
that's laying around in Starks workspace
which just feels like an unnecessary
Marvel geek out too much too fast test
with following up the surprising success
of Iron Man but the deck was arguably
stacked against Iron Man 2 this sequel
was also the last chance of the MCU to
lay some groundwork for the Avengers
Black Widow
Nick Fury and Agent Coulson were written
into supporting roles to establish the
paths that eventually play in The
Avengers I get my hiring with Iron Man
dealing with a personal crisis on a bad
guy
it felt forced to see Nick Fury waving
from the sidelines trying to shoehorn in
the fact that there's a bigger world out
there when we haven't even met half of
the Avengers yet it was a classic
example of show don't tell and Iron Man
too did a lot of telling plans changed
though he's since been replaced by Taika
Waititi
Joss Whedon and Shane black director Jon
Favreau helped to lay the groundwork for
the MCU fans no one loved today as the
director of iron man he used his passion
and talent to establish a tone that
would carry on through more than a dozen
subsequent movies
Favreau also had his own ideas mapped
out for an Iron Man trilogy plan to
explore the demon in a bottle storyline
from the comics which focused on starts
alcoholism
however Marvel wanted a more
family-friendly approach
it seems Faro may have had more
storytelling freedom in the early days
back before Marvel realized iron man was
a golden goose marvel's villain problem
almost every Marvel movie has a problem
when it comes to their bad guys Marvel
puts great thought into its heroes but
they're evil foils often leave much to
be desired looking back we can trace the
origin of the MC use villain problems to
Iron Man to Mickey Rourke is one heck of
a talented actor a fact that made his 1
no performance as Ivan Vanko a gruff
Russian folk all the more frustrating
but I don't speak Russian rogue says he
wanted to add other layers and color not
just make this Russian a complete
murderous revenge in bad guy according
to him though a good chunk of his
performance wound up on the cutting room
floor considering how much Marvel was
trying to cram into this movie it's not
a surprise that Vanko story was cut
short but it still makes you wonder what
could have been there was also vanko's
partner Justin Hammer in the comics and
there was a legitimate corporate rival
to Tony Stark in Iron Man 2 he's little
more than a punch line leading to an
awkward pairing of slapstick and a
menace that was one of the weakest
aspects of an already weak film instead
of one quality villain Iron Man 2 gave
us two subpar ones there are 125 point 7
million a pop so Oh
the sequel trap when it comes to making
a sequel most Studios tried to go bigger
and badder and dine man 2 fell into that
same formula it had more characters more
team ups bigger set pieces and whackier
villains but simply Iron Man 2 tried to
go too big too fast following the film's
release Robert Downey jr. admitted that
they may have tried too hard to make the
film bigger rather than making it good
there's little doubt that this problem
was exacerbated by all the heavy lifting
to lay the groundwork for the Avengers
Iron Man 2 at the deck stacked against
it from the start is it good
Marvel Studios is at the top of
Hollywood these days but back when Iron
Man 2 arrived it was still figuring out
how to make all these big movies while
keeping the quality level high
Iron Man 2 has
aged well either as Collider notes the
film feels rushed bloated and steady and
unfocused it's a perfect example of
everything not to do it still made a ton
of money at the box office but there's
no doubt some funds were turned off by
its convoluted plot zany bad guys and
excessive foundation laying Marvel
learned a lot from this movie and these
lessons likely helped Marvel make the
Avenger such a crowd-pleaser but we all
have to watch this dirt to get there
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]